I think I heard you advised writers to
be comfortable with solitude and I think
a lot of creative people embrace this
romantic notion of being alone and
creating something but how real what
week because you talked about this
earlier we're social animals and we
don't work herd animals - how realistic
is that for people to be alone and and
do what it is they say they want to do
yeah it really depends on the writer
there are writers who are okay with
solitude they're able to be by
themselves for many many hours days
years and that's I like to call it the
temperament of the artist that there are
people who are meant to be artists
because they have the right temperament
for it they're able there even though
they're social animals maybe they're
okay with not being social and so
they're able to do this other writers
are not so able to do this but you can
still be writers and be in a social
environment for example I know writers
who gravitate toward television not
because now televisions the golden age
of television but because they're more
it's a more it's a more social activity
in being a TV writer you're in a writers
room you have with other writers you
create with other writers when I was
speaking to Akiva Goldsman in in for the
101 habits book he talked about how he
loves the balance of being a writer and
a producer he loves being a producer
because being a writer is by himself and
alone and then being a producer he gets
to be on set and being socially with
other people so it's a good balance so
you could have 100% all social and still
be a writer you know there's writing
teams you know Billy Wilder wrote with
partners throughout his career so
there's that social aspect of it being
in the room with somebody else and then
his writers who are okay with being by
themselves and and ripen you know alone
in and kind of being social afterwards
you know with their friends or on the
set what about for you for me I'm one of
those one of those writers who are very
comfortable with their solitude you know
I mean I come from art and artistic
family and they're you know they they're
okay with you know I guess it's a
genetic I'm okay with being alone so
there's a difference between being alone
and lonely this that's
difference so you know and so that's me
you know do you think that's more
embrace I like how you said that there
is a difference between being alone and
lonely in Western culture versus other
cultures do you think it's more endure
it there there is that distinction where
is I think a lot of Western culture yeah
I understand
right right but it is is definitely it's
part of the artists makeup you know
there's I think I think certain people
are meant to be artists not because
they're creative but because they're
they're emotional being is able to
accept that you know there's no doubt
that being an artist you have to be
alone to in solitude to create unless
you have a partner and you're doing it
together but most true artists are
solitary you know and and you're right
in in a Western society it's it's
frowned upon you know they would see
somebody who's alone as somebody who's
like you know a potential serial killer
or something you know it's just not it's
frowned upon you know well even eating
at restaurants alone well especially for
a woman they think oh she couldn't find
something right exactly there is yeah
such a stigma there absolutely that's
what you have to live with you know
right but so that goes back to the S
word being selfish yeah so if the
difference between being alone and
lonely and people actually draw energy
from being alone which is I guess the
definition of an introvert right um is
it okay again how do we tie that in
where it's not necessarily selfish but
you it's more self-care it's up to you
it's how much you can take it's it
really depends on on how much do you
care about what other people say how
much do you care about that you know I
mean I see people for example you're
right somebody who dines alone in a
restaurant
surrounded by social animals and they by
themselves will know that they're
getting the stairs and the stigma and
the judgments right but if they don't
care they're gonna be okay with it it's
only people who care about now I'll be
honest with you I I care you know I mean
like I would I would not eat at a
restaurant although and even though I
probably feel you know be great
to taste the food and enjoy the
experience but because of the fact that
I know I will be judged and negatively I
try to avoid that I also had that
problem with going to the movies alone
but now it's less now I don't care about
movies but restaurants are still care
about that so if I want to taste the
food I would just get the food to go and
eat you know eat in my place with with
the actual food so I'll get to taste the
food but but yeah because see so that's
the difference between how much do you
care about how much are you're aware of
what people are thinking about you
that's it because you're right it is a
negative stigma
you